my name is Peter salivate on the Dean of
your college and I welcome you to the
first in the hundred and fiftieth year
celebration I'll tell you of what in a
moment first of all let me apologize
obviously we are in a room too small for
the number of you number of you who
would like to hear Dean code today we
understand that all other room options
are in use and so I would ask you to
come and sit down in the aisle and there
is a little more room on either side and
for those of you are still out in the
hall we will do our best to project
voices out there but we do apologize we
can see that there are more people who
would have liked to have been here today
then we'll fit in the room this year we
celebrate the fact that a hundred and
fifty years ago a man who yell students
know as young wing but whose name in
Mandarin is really pronounced wrong Hong
was the first person from China to
graduate from Yale and in fact the first
Asian to obtain a bachelor's degree from
any university in north america so this
celebration our celebration this year
commemorates more than wrong hung or
young wingz achievements but really
demarcates 150 year relationship between
yale and china that continues today in
many different ways i think for example
that many of you are aware that the
leaders but more than a dozen of china's
most outstanding universities visited
yell for two weeks in august now back to
wrong hung or formerly known as young
wing born in 1828 in a small village in
the guangdong province wrong received
his early education in a missionary
school under a Yale graduate the
Reverend Samuel Robbins brown young
accompanied Brown to the United States
in 1847 where he enrolled in the months
and Academy in Massachusetts and later
at Yale after graduation
young or wrong returned to China where
he engaged in projects to promote
China's modernization many Chinese
school children can tell you Ron's story
and one of the chinese university
presidents who visited in august said to
us that you can trace the evolution of
the modern chinese railway system to him
he is also known for organizing the
chinese educational mission which
brought 120 chinese students in the
1870s to colleges in the northeast
including yell many of these students
went on to play important roles in
China's development in the decades that
followed in 1877 wrong donated more than
1,200 Chinese books the first of their
kind in the United States to yell and
this donation formed the nucleus of the
university's East Asian collection which
today is considered one of the finest in
the West who knew that in the 1870s
thought the 120 students participating
in the Chinese educational mission to
yell would grow to more than 700,000
Chinese students and scholars who have
participated in educational programs
throughout the world's colleges and
universities just in the last several
decades and especially to the special
relationship between Yale and China this
is a portrait that hangs in the visitors
center at Yale University of Hong Hong
or young wing and it really is a
pleasure to see him up in front of this
room in the company of wilbur cross who
was Dean of the Graduate School of Arts
and Sciences and later became governor
of Connecticut and over here is Edgar
furnace who was dean of graduate school
and a also the Provost actually at the
same time and over there is Thorstein
Veblen who as a sociologist who moved
from yella went onto to Stanford some of
you many may know his work on the
leisure class so today we inaugurate the
wrong hung or young wing lecture series
with a presentation by Harold hung juco
who became Dean of the law school this
year Dean co was educated at
Harvard and at Oxford University's after
law school he clerked for judge Malcolm
Richard Wilkie of the US Court of
Appeals DC Circuit and then for justice
Harry Blackmun of the US Supreme Court
after holding positions in the
Department of Justice he joined the L
faculty in 1985 rising through the
professorial ranks and directing the law
schools Orville HL center for
international human rights from nineteen
ninety eight to two thousand one he
served as the assistant secretary of
state for democracy human rights and
labor under President Clinton he has
received more than 20 awards for his
human rights work and was named by
American Lawyer magazine as one of the
nation's 45 leading public sector
lawyers under the age of 45 I won't
embarrass him by asking him if that's
still a true statement okay Dean Co has
published many books including the
National Security Constitution
transnational legal problems
deliberative democracy and human rights
transnational business problems the
human rights of persons with
intellectual disabilities the Harry a
Blackman oral history project and
foundations of international law and
relations so today I'm proud to
introduce Dean Harold Koh the gerald c
and bernice latrobe smith professor of
international law whose talk is titled
yellow in a white world
hey thank you Peter for that most
generous introduction as the father of a
happy Yale freshman let me say that Yale
College is very lucky to have a Dean
like you I also want to thank the
asian-american cultural center for
organizing this event and the offices of
the President the Secretary the Graduate
School and the association of Yale
alumni for joining hands to make this
lecture series happen let me start with
an embarrassing confession I've lived in
new haven for 43 years I've taught as
Peter said here for nearly 20 years but
until I was asked to give this lecture I
had never heard of young wing or at
least so I thought more on that in a
moment who was young wing as you've just
heard he was the first Asian to graduate
from Yale he was probably the first
Asian to obtain a bachelor's degree from
any American University and so in a very
real sense he is the spiritual ancestor
of every one of us of Asian heritage who
studies or works here at Yale today by
all accounts he was a remarkable person
he was born near the island of mchale in
guangdong province in 1828 and when he
was just seven years old he was brought
to meet mrs. good sloth who is the wife
of an English missionary who had opened
a Christian school near his home mrs.
goot sloth apparently bore little
resemblance to Deborah car who we saw in
the king and i singing
getting-to-know-you cheerfully to a
smiling throng of Asian children mrs.
good sloth was a huge imposing and
frightening woman
as young wing recalls in his
autobiography which I encourage you all
to read my life in China and America as
mrs. good Slav came forward to welcome
me in her long and full flowing white
dress I actually trembled all over with
fear at her imposing proportions I clung
to my father in fear a new world had
dawned on me from that day forward young
wing had become a yellow man in a white
world at the beginning young wing hated
his English school so much he tried to
run away from it but overcoming his fear
as Peter mentioned he progressed from
her school to another missionary school
where he met the Reverend Samuel Robbins
Brown who held his doctorate in divinity
from Yale and so young wing began to
dream about crossing the Pacific he
wrote an essay for school called an
imaginary voyage to New York and up the
hudson and just two years later he made
that voyage for real when he came with
dr. Brown to the u.s. to attend monson
academy in Massachusetts by good fortune
the principle of Munson Academy was the
Reverend Charles Hammond who was also a
Yale graduate and so it came to pass
that in 1850 with financial aid provided
by a scholarship from the ladies
Association of Savannah Georgia where
dr. Brown's sister happened to live
young wing became the first Asian ever
to enroll in Yale College as you can
imagine Yale in the mid 19th century was
not an easy place for young wing his
class had only 98 members it had
precious few people of color no women
virtually no non-christians as the only
yellow in a white world young wing was
at best a curiosity and at worst a freak
during his freshman year he didn't make
matters any easier because he wore his
Chinese tunic and he wore his hair and a
topknot
by freshman year he chose to dress and
groom like Americans and I don't think
he was wearing a t-shirt baggy jeans and
a backward baseball cap he looked more
like this like many freshman he sweated
over his studies till midnight every
night or at least my freshman daughter
tells me so he worked so hard he took
little or no exercise he had almost no
social life his sophomore year he almost
flunked differential and integral
calculus in his autobiography he said I
absolutely abhorred and to tested that
subject to pay for his tuition and he
worked as a waiter in his residential
college he worked as a librarian in one
of the college debating societies but
remarkably in the words of one of his
admirers he made a sensation that was
felt beyond the college walls by bearing
off repeated prizes for English
Composition think about this coming from
China in 10th Grade and winning the Yale
prizes in English competition for
several years in a row Asia and its
needs were never far from young wingz
mind he took long walks with his
classmate Carol Cutler who later became
president of Western Reserve college now
Case Western Reserve in Cleveland and
they discussed how to ensure that the
rising generation in China would have
the same advantages that young wing had
enjoyed they came up with the idea of an
educational mission where by the Chinese
government would send hundreds of
students like young wing to America for
their education and when young wing
graduated in 1854 a hundred and fifty
years ago he sailed for Hong Kong that
voyage took 151 days when they arrived
in hong kong harbor the chinese pilot
came on board and young one was shocked
to discover that when he spoke the pilot
could not understand him his chinese had
deteriorated to that extent and when the
pilot spoke young wing could only
understand
what he said with great difficulty in
other words he found himself so changed
by his Western experience that he now
felt out of place everywhere including
even in his homeland like many of us who
navigate to cultures young wing was
caught between two stools in America he
felt Asian in Asia he felt American he
became a naturalized citizen in the
United States in his junior year at Yale
but when he came back for his 10th
reunion he volunteered to fight in the
University in the Union Army during the
Civil War incredibly his offer was
declined because he was not really an
American and not only had he almost
forgotten how to speak Chinese but
having left China as a young boy he now
had no friends in China in the words of
dr. Twitchell his biographer he could
not fail to encounter among his own
people prejudice suspicion and hostility
now think about this with this history
how could you have blamed him if he had
given up any plan and simply sought bat
to fit back into his Chinese life but
instead young wing continued to engage
in many projects to promote China's
modernization he went to work for the
tea and silk business and in 1964
entered the service of the Ching dynasty
chinese government and because of his
english language skill he was
commissioned to purchase arms and
machinery in the US for the chinese
military and then in 1870 the tents and
massacre occurred in which a Chinese mob
murdered a number of male and female
Roman Catholic missionaries to
compensate the Chinese government
appointed a commission to figure out how
to make compensation and so young wing
remembering his discussions with his
friends at Yale submitted a proposal to
the High Commissioners suggesting that
China said more than a hundred Chinese
youth abroad to promote mutual cultural
understanding and to extend the reach of
the Chinese Empire and so it was that in
the late 1870s the so-called young wing
mission began where some 120 Chinese
boys and girls came to the u.s. to study
at schools and colleges through
the Northeast including at Yale the
leader who was sent to supervise the
mission was young wing himself 18 years
after his college graduation he came
back to New Haven to set up the mission
and eventually placed its headquarters
in Hartford there he started Hartford's
progressive Chinese educational
commission school three years later he
married an American woman Mary Kellogg
of Avon Connecticut and in 1876 young
wing received an honorary degree from
Yale Law School which makes him i'm
almost sure the first asian ever to
receive a degree from school of the
school of which i am now the Dean now
fearing that American America was
corrupting the Chinese students they
were after all starting to dress like
this China's conservatives abruptly
terminated the mission in 1881 and
called the students back but they had
been here long enough during the nine
years they studied in Hartford they gave
china her first generation of 20th
century railroad builders engineers
medical doctors naval Admirals and
diplomats and in the decades ahead they
went on to play many important roles in
China's own development as for young
wing himself he became a full-fledged
diplomat he went to Peru he came to
Washington he was appointed an official
of one of the Chinese provinces and when
his wife fell ill he came back to
Hartford where he nursed her until she
died in 1886 if you go to the Cedar Hill
Cemetery in Hartford you see both of
their tombstones their two sons Morrison
and Bartlett both went to Yale and his
grandson Frank young who lives in Hong
Kong returned to Yale four years ago for
the unveiling of this portrait the
portrait of his grandfather the first
Asian at Yale now I've told the story in
some detail because all many know almost
nobody knows that story I didn't know
that story and perhaps in young wingz
story you've heard echoes of your own
life let me tell you how young wingz
story rez
nates with my own my parents came to the
u.s. from Korea about a hundred years
after young wing my mother was a
freshman in college my father went to
graduate school and became one of the
first Koreans if not the first Korean to
get a law degree in America like young
wing my parents came away from their
educational experience determined to
promote mutual understanding between the
United States and their home country
Korea and when in 1960 the first
democratically elected government came
to power in South Korea my late father
dr. quang nam co was appointed first
korean ambassador to the United Nations
and then Korean minister to the United
States in Washington in 1961 a military
coup overthrew my father's democratic
government and he turned for help to
Walt Rostow who was then deputy national
security adviser Walt called his brother
Eugene who is Dean of Yale Law School
and suggested that my parents be offered
a position to teach East Asian law and
society at Yale Law School the first
such course ever offered in this country
and so it was in 1961 43 years ago that
my family moved here to New Haven and i
entered the halls of Yale Law School and
I've been here ever since
like young wing my parents helped
hundreds of Korean students come here to
study so many Korean students came to
dinner at my house that we had a regular
chair that was just left available for
whoever was coming to dinner that night
my father had no shame whenever anybody
would come to his house he would invite
them to dinner but my mother was who is
here was smarter than that she always
made noodles and whenever a Korean would
appear or two or three or four with my
father she would sigh and dump some more
noodles into the pot and went as
assistant secretary of state i went back
to korea a few years ago hundreds of
well-meaning korean government officials
came and said I dinner at your house and
I thought to myself so what else is new
except one night it paid off I digress
but I have to tell this story on the
night that I went with President Clinton
to Korea and we are invited to a state
dinner the American side had only a
limited number of seats and so my mother
who is in Seoul couldn't join me there
and I called the Korean ambassador to
the United States and I introduced
myself and he said oh yes I ate dinner
at your house and I said yes and today's
the day that you're going to return the
favor
and with that my mother and I went to a
state dinner together I shall also tell
you that I quickly assured you her that
President Clinton may not remember who I
was or remember who she was of course as
we approached he leaned over and said
mrs. Koh I'm so happy to meet you aren't
we lucky to have your son in my
government at which point my mother said
you know President Clinton is quite a
handsome man in 1952 my parents founded
the east rock institute a nonprofit
organization on Dwight street where it
still remains its mission is promoting
cultural understanding between the East
and the West 30 years ago they started
an annual conference on Koreans and
Korean Americans which last year ripened
into the National Conference of Korean
American students cask on that was held
here at Yale both of my parents also
went on to teach at various universities
here in Connecticut and my father for
one became fascinated with the story of
the young wing educational mission he
spent many days seeking out the story
his students wrote term papers about the
later history of the students one of
young wingz students have a daughter who
came and would join my father as a
colleague and she told him many tales
about what had happened to the young
wing students some became government
officials of China others educators some
ambassadors one even became the Chinese
ambassador to Korea of all things and so
it was that yesterday while preparing
for this lecture I suddenly realized
that I did know young wing after all I
had first heard of him at our family
dinner table 35 years ago well what does
young wingz story tell us young wingz
story tells us what it means to be
yellow in a white world it is a story of
choices it's a story
hope it's a story of obligations and
it's a story of accomplishment let me
say a word about each first and most
obviously young wingz story is a lesson
about making our own choices however
difficult they might be how easy it
would have been for young wing to stay
in China his whole life or once he
returned from his time in the US how
easy it would have been trimmed to stay
instead he spent his life coming back
and forth between his two countries and
by marrying an American woman he
intentionally divided his life so now he
lies buried in a place far distant from
where he was born he consciously placed
himself between two cultures even though
the price was he never felt truly at
home at either place and he not only
made choices he took tremendous risks
and tremendous risks now I told you that
my father was an international lawyer a
professor and a diplomat and so when I
was a boy you might have imagined that
he would have urged me his son also to
be an international lawyer a professor
and in diplomat and indeed one day when
I was in elementary school we were
watching the lawyer show Perry Mason and
I turned to my father and asked dad do
you think I should be a lawyer and my
father turned to me and said just two
words study physics
his words had a profound influence on me
I followed them for nearly 10 years
until I finally gave it up in my
sophomore year of college and it was not
until many years later that I realized
that underlie my father's urging were
four assumptions and their assumptions
that are about choices first he was
saying law is a confrontational
profession and confrontation is not our
way we are Pacific people in both senses
of that word we believe not in
confrontation or adversary process but
in harmony and order and so we should
not follow law because law is not our
way second he was saying english is the
language of law and english is not our
language and so we cannot study law
because it law is not our language third
I think he was saying law is for
insiders and we are outsiders in this
country it rests on old boy networks and
we are new boys here and fourth and
finally law is not an exact science and
we will suffer from its in exactness how
often I came home to find on my desk a
story that he had clipped from the New
York Times it usually said Chinese
physicist or Japanese mathematician wins
the Nobel Prize
I'm sure that's never happened to any of
you if an Asian is a better
mathematician or scientist he seemed to
say the numbers will not lie now when
you think about it each of these were
reasons why for him physics made sense
for me physics is a universal language
we can all speak it physics has its own
harm in the order physics is a
profession that's equally open to Asians
and whites alike and in exact Sciences
they cannot discriminate against you if
you're better the numbers don't lie well
his position had its logic and the Asian
part of me accepted it but as you can
imagine the Americans side rebelled I
thought what do you mean English is not
our language I spoken it since I was a
boy I 1 English prizes like young wing
it is my language I use it every day and
what do you mean we're not adversarial I
can do the Pacific side of law as well
as anyone I was on the debate team for
Christ's sake an insider's network may
rely on politics but I felt that that
politics was not foreign to me and
finally it didn't matter that law was
not an exact science because it turned
out I wasn't very good at exact science
as an Asian this was difficult because
if I simply did not speak in class and
not in my head I intimidated others and
thus if I spoke I would reveal my
ignorance and so it was not until well
into my sophomore year that I finally
decided that physics was not my business
and I switched to pre-law I became a
lawyer and it was my choice for better
for worse it's a choice that I feel
better about every day and surprisingly
it was a choice that actually gratified
my father when I told him I was becoming
a lawyer at a large Washington firm he
said to me with a frown on his face you
know in Korea being a lawyer is the
second most despised profession I said
what's the most despised professional he
said being an actor and then he asked me
when I went to the US Department of
Justice who is your client and I said
well I guess ultimately Ronald Reagan
and he said you mean you're a lawyer for
an actor but when i came to yale and
became a professor of international law
he said well now your professor and
you're an international lawyer and maybe
someday you'll be a diplomat just like
your father now there's a second lesson
that we learned from young wing and that
is a story of hope the possibility of
overcoming discrimination it was almost
exactly a hundred years after young wing
graduated from Yale that our supreme
court decided Brown versus the Board of
Education and I was born just months
later I first viscerally met the
challenges of brown in 1959 when during
my father's time in the Korean embassy
my parents moved our family to takoma
park maryland and on his first day of
school my older brother came home to
me that his third grade class was half
white and half black and when recess was
called the black kids and the white kids
had silently divided into two baseball
teams and started playing against each
other and as the only yellow my brother
literally didn't know what team he was
supposed to be on and so he SAT there
alone for all of recess understanding
for the first time what it meant to be
isolated by racial segregation by five
years later we had moved here to New
Haven where I attended the Edgewood
Avenue School in westville and during my
sixth grade year students from
inner-city New Haven were bused into our
class the girl who had been sitting next
to me for three years cleared out her
desk and a new boy sat next to me he was
a wiry short african-american named
Richard and for several days we SAT a
few inches apart and finally he leaned
over and said man this classroom is much
nicer than the one we were in and so I
learned how integration can breed
understanding and how separate but equal
facilities are inherently unequal one
day Richard ask me who's the greatest
baseball player of all time I told him
as I had usually done babe ruth and he
said to me man you're wrong for some
reason he always called me man even
though I was only 10 years old
I asked him Richard who do you think is
the greatest baseball player of all time
and he answered Jackie Robinson number
42 when I asked why he answered because
Jackie did everything babe did and at a
time when everyone wanted him to fail I
thought about it and since then when
everyone asked me who is the greatest
baseball of all time my answer Jackie
Robinson number 42 I remember that story
when I was in law school and read
Richard cloggers masterpiece simple
justice the story of the brown
litigation at that point I was a lawyer
in training and sarvis is moved by the
story the lawyers is by the clients and
I read about the partnership between
African American lawyers like Thurgood
Marshall spotswood Robinson constance
baker motley and white attorneys like
Jack Greenberg and future law professors
like Dean Louis Pollock of the Yale Law
School and Charles black of the Yale Law
School I read about how the lawyers and
brown argued cases in towns where they
could not eat in local restaurants where
they could not sleep in the local hotels
how they type their briefs in the back
of their cars how they cited cases from
memory because they had no libraries and
nevertheless they want case after case
before hostel courts culminating in the
unanimous victory and brown itself and I
concluded that like Jackie Robinson
Thurgood Marshall was the greatest
lawyer of all time because he did
everything that Daniel Webster did and
won a promise of equality for millions
when so many wanted him to fail now I'm
like Thurgood Marshall young wing was a
pioneer think of how lonely he must have
been when he was at Yale think of how
discouraged he must have been when his
mission was recalled to China how could
he have imagined the changes that lay
ahead when I was in law school there
were almost no Asians in my class at
Harvard Law School in the late 1970s the
Koreans American student society
consisted of two people myself and my
sister Jean
hey when the names of asians would
appear in Supreme Court cases names like
ye quo or phone you ting or wonk in arc
or Hirabayashi or korematsu there were
always litigants and never lawyers and
on the rare occasions that those cases
were mentioned the other students would
snicker the history of asian-americans
at the Supreme Court is a story of
unbroken sadness it's a story of what it
means to be yellow in a white world it's
not a story of Victor's and justice it's
a story of victims and injustice it's a
story of Americans who were treated like
they were foreigners they were
victimized in the words of justice
Jackson's unforgettable dissent in
korematsu because quote they were born
of parents as Tim they had no choice and
because they belong to a race from which
there is no way to resign well what has
changed if you look over our classrooms
now you see a very different picture
there are now in the latest census the
2,000 census more than 10 million Asians
in America a forty-eight percent
increase since 10 years earlier there
are two point four million Chinese 1.9
million Filipinos 1.7 Indian Americans
or Pakistani Americans 1.1 million
Vietnamese a million Koreans 800,000
Japanese Asians now form nearly four
percent of the population and if you
look over our classrooms at Yale at Yale
Law School you see a huge increase in
the number of yellow faces more than
that the world is not nearly as white as
it was there are many more Hispanics in
these classes Native Americans foreign
students the United States has become a
strikingly diverse country and the
number of asians are growing Asians by
birth Asians by adoption Asians by
marriage and Asians by choice and scores
of asians are in our very classes
and the other day or the other month I
went to bulldog days which is where the
parents of incoming Yale freshman go
other parents were quite cool but not
the Asians they would come up to the
other Asians and say son or daughter and
then when you'd give them the answer
they would shake your hands and
congratulate you one of them turned to
me and said I hear the faculty here is
excellent I said yes I agree what we
have now is a different kind of Asian
experience in my day Koreans were
minorities within the minority and we
separated ourselves from the other Asian
groups but now the story is told by the
annual dinner that the Asian students
Pacific Asian and Native American
students have at yale law school they go
to east buffet where they have a
pan-asian meal and all sit together
trying each other's cuisines and
rejoicing in their cultural unity now
there is a third kind of our third part
of young wing story and that is a story
of obligation he could have pursued his
private interest but instead he felt a
sense of public service of obligation to
his community in the words of the
filmmaker Spike Lee he felt he had a
duty to uplift his race he thought that
the is of race consciousness should lead
him to the art of making it an
obligation to do something for his race
what kind of obligations are we talking
about think for images a bridge a ladder
a beacon a boat remember that he
positioned himself between two cultures
the thing that ultimately swung me away
from physics and toward the field that
I'm now in is the reason is the is the
realization that somehow fate had put me
between two cultures Asia and the West
and so it could be that the only
profession in which this would be in
Vantage is one in which i served as a
bridge between these two cultures and so
it was for young wing as a physics major
and the fact that I was Asian would be
irrelevant to whether I was a
professional success and what about a
ladder young wing saw it as his goal to
provide others a step up toward the same
kind of education that he had himself
achieved and as a beacon he was saying
this if you stand out as you will
because you're Asian then maybe you have
an obligation to actually stand out to
be distinctive to be peculiarly
admirable in your commitments and
finally I believe young wing was telling
us of the need for an obligation to all
of those who are in the same boat a
number of years I had the good fortune
to represent Haitian refugees in an
effort to gain asylum in the United
States I worked on this case for several
years and was often engaged in public
speaking on the subject and I remember
coming to an asian gathering and one
asian americans stood up and said why
are you wasting your time representing
black patients why don't you represent
our people to which i responded do you
mean to say that in the face of the
haitian exclusion you don't see the
chinese exclusion do you mean to say
that in the patient internment you don't
see the japanese internment do you mean
to say that in the deprivation of
Haitian democracy you don't see Korean
democracy do you mean to say that in the
face of patient both people you don't
see Vietnamese boat people because we
may all have come in different boats but
we are all in the same boat now so this
I believe is where our obligation lies
to be a bridge between two cultures to
be a ladder for the
those who come behind to be a beacon for
those who would look to us for
leadership because of our unique
educational advantages and and most of
all to represent not just those people
who are like us in appearance but those
who stand for the same principles and
fourth and finally let me say this young
wingz story is a story of accomplishment
a legacy of accomplishment what his
story tells you is how one person even a
solitaire yellow in a white world can
make a difference Dean sallow they
reviewed the ways in which young wingz
legacy continues here at Yale in one of
his last acts he donated his book
collection which now forms the nucleus
of the Sterling Memorial libraries East
Asian collection one of the finest in
the West in 1901 the Yale foreign
missionary society was formed promote
contact with China and English language
instruction it became known as the Yale
in china association and now that yale
china association which to this day
sends dozens of recent Yale graduates
annually to teach English and American
Studies overseas and at the law school
where I teach another legacy of young
wing is the law schools China Law Center
which is represented here by my
colleague and friend professor quartz it
is a distinctive institution devoted to
increasing understanding of China's
legal system supporting his legal reform
and to this end the center sponsors
research promotes academic exchange and
undertakes cooperative projects on key
issues of legal reform including
judicial reform administrative law and
legal education the population of Yale
College is now thirteen to fifteen
percent Asian American and international
students about ten percent of the
international students at Yale are of
asian ancestry and just to show that
people can change institutions that
institutions can build legacies and that
legacies can make history just consider
how events have now come full circle
forty-three years after my family
arrived in New Haven
my sister jean co Peters is a professor
at Yale Law School where I am now the
Dean and this fall my daughter entered
the Yale class of two thousand eight
from which she will graduate sixty years
after my parents first came to America
and more than 150 years after young wing
and just a week before her classes began
as Jeanne salvi mentioned the presidents
and vice-presidents of twelve of china's
leading universities came to new haven
for a session on the American University
and so in late August I had the
incredible experience and warm
experience of sitting in Woolsey Hall
still yellow in a white world but now
finding myself not just an American
citizen a lifelong resident of New Haven
but the Dean of Yale's law school the
father of EE L freshman the brother of a
Yale professor and listening to my
friend Yale's president described a
modern-day Chinese mission to New Haven
to all the incoming freshmen in their
parents as proof of Yale's genuine 21st
century commitment to globalization so
in the end let me say this what one
young wingz story and my and yours tells
you is how remarkably open a society
America still is a few years ago I was
representing the United States to the UN
Human Rights Commission in Geneva and I
sat at dinner next to the Bangladeshi
ambassador to the UN we struck up a
conversation and we told each other our
life stories and at the end he looked
over at me and said so what you're
telling me is that your father was an
ambassador to the United States and in
one generation you have become
ambassador from the United States in
Bangladesh that could never happen
America is the only country in the world
where that could happen and I have to
believe that is why you are the
mightiest nation I hope that our leaders
our political leaders remember this that
our openness leads to our diversity that
I diversity gives rise to our sense of
justice and that our justice is the
source of
our power our moral power and so my
friends that's young wingz story it's a
story of what it means to be yellow in a
white world it is a story of choices
it's a story of hope it's a story of
obligation it's a story of
accomplishment and most of all I think
it's the story of justice the justice
that asian-americans seek and the
justice that asian-americans can create
with the help of their friends and their
colleagues when I was a small boy I
watched a lot of television as opposed
to now when I watch a lot of television
and one of my favorite shows was a show
called the Texas Rangers and it would
start with a small town and into a busy
street would step a single Texas Ranger
walking along fearless Lee and then
suddenly behind him to then four then
eight and 16 until the street was full
of Texas Rangers think of this as young
wing and his mission followed by all of
us as Martin Luther King jr. once said
the moral arc of the universe is long
but it arcs toward justice the moral arc
of the universe is long but it arcs
toward justice and if young wing we're
here I think he would have to agree
thank you very much
come Sam be done Dean co is quite
willing to take some questions for if
anyone would like to ask them don't be
shy cuz I'm gonna call on
yes
you
well I think there's a long answer and
there's a short answer the long answer
which I just gave is you must make some
difficult choices you must take some
risks you should have hope you should
remember your obligations and you should
follow others accomplishments but the
short answer is one that my mother and
grandmother used to give it's an old
Korean saying never let your skill
exceed your virtue think about this
never let your skill exceed your virtue
we spend a lot of time here at Yale in
the undergraduate and in the
professional schools and then the
graduate schools honing students skills
and we assume often that their virtue
will take care of itself but i believe
that while you're here at yale your
skill will grow quickly and so your
virtue has to grow even faster and there
has to be a source within you of these
values i should say it's quite a
surprise to me to be a source of public
interest in korea part of this happened
because when i was first appointed to
the State Department the Korean
government are the Korean economy was in
the middle of a financial crisis and
they needed some good news story to
balance this and the good news story was
basically the success of a woman golfer
sri park and my appointment to be in the
state department so often on the cover
of various versions of korean people
magazine where myself in surrey park and
then in the corner little word saying
things like financial crisis continuing
then of course my mother has become
extraordinarily famous in Korea and so
now they often have Harold Cole and his
mother and then the basic statement is
Harold what is your advice and my advice
is always listen to my mother
well China is one-fifth of mankind
humankind and any great University
global university must have a plan to
address the modernization and
globalization of China's economy
political system and legal system and I
believe that Yale Law School is at the
forefront of that in no small measure
because of our long history with China
because of the commitment of our
academic leaders because of the creation
of the China Law Center created by
Professor courts I also believe that we
are at a time when universities are
going global and that not all american
universities will achieve global stature
we may want it to be so but I believe in
10 years many of the fine universities
of America will be in the global world
like the small liberal arts colleges are
now excellent centers of education but
not leading centers of research and not
leading centers of interchange and so I
think a key goal for us here at Yale is
to keep Yale as one of the global
universities now on the East Coast is
easy for us to look
toward Europe and indeed our strength
has traditionally been in the humanities
but I believe that the humanities and
particularly Western studies cannot be
the dominant part of our curriculum and
I believe that our strength is precisely
in these areas social science and the
professional schools and one of the core
elements of my agenda as the incoming
dean is globalization and particularly
with regard to East Asia now I don't
know what other school is in contention
to do the same I don't notice that any
of them appointed in Asian Dean in any
time recently I think this is a natural
leaning of my own as you know that when
the americans landed on Normandy Beach
on d-day they said Lafayette we have
arrived and I think that's our answer to
young wing we have arrived and the
globalization project particularly with
regard to East Asia will continue with
regard to China in particular I think
the challenge is to bring China into the
international system claiming by the
international rules whether that means
international trade rules rules about
corruption rules about good governance
or rules about human rights or
environmental standards I think
one-fifth of the world's people cannot
be outside of the international system
but if they had if they enter the
international system they have to be
full-fledged members fully subject to
the system's duties and fully subject to
its privileges yes in the back
well you know hyphenated Americans one
of the good advantages of going to many
conferences about Asian American
identity it's a little bit like having
years and years of therapy after a while
you come to the solution that you're
going to live with and then you go on
from there as a boy I would think my
fifty percent of the Asian fifty percent
american or sixty forty or and when am i
going to solve this problem well I now
have concluded I don't solve this
problem any more than I solve the
problem of how to keep my teeth clean
every morning when I brush my teeth the
problem was there again the next day I
believe that hyphenated Americans are
Americans my daughter is an
asian-american also as my son their
mother is a Caucasian an irish-american
and so they are yet another blend
fortunately we now have a word to
describe this fusion they are fusion
Americans I believe that there are a
number of issues which I've described
which I believe ought to be a focal
point of concern take for example the
issue of immigration what possible
rationale is there from limiting student
visas to Asian and Chinese Americans
Chinese students in particular in the
name of terrorism at a time in which
we're trying to promote understanding
between our culture's I think this is
outrageous most recently I heard the
story of an Islamic students who is one
of the leading students in Iran who was
prevented from coming to study at
another university even though he was
arguably the best student in his class
in Iran now if we want to create a
generation of people who are not
committed to terrorism as opposed to the
rule of law is their way of doing
business what sense does it make these
make to keep these people out as opposed
to coming to study what we learned from
the lesson of young wing is that
coming here breathes a closest a kind of
mutual understanding promotes ties
networks at a person-to-person private
level which can trump all manner of
governmental foolishness and I think
that that's what we should be promoting
here as well at the very moment where
it's very difficult to arrange meetings
of governmental officials from certain
countries it's quite easy if we can get
over these issues and others to arrange
academic meetings and that's where the
free exchange of ideas I think can keep
the process of humane globalization
moving forward yes in the middle
I think asian americans are a
risk-averse people risk-averse I say
that because I was extraordinarily
risk-averse it was not until I got
tenure at Yale Law School that I started
thinking it might be safe for me to try
to try to do something that was less
risk-averse now i'm not sure where this
risk aversion comes from I think
immigrant parents often convey to their
children the feeling having abandoned
our life in our home country to come
here we don't want you to do anything
risky in fact the world is made by bold
people look at young wing what he did
was insane insanely risky but by being
so risky he made an impact and I guess
I'd say to Asian Americans of the next
generation what are you waiting for
isn't it time to take a stand on
something don't you want to change the
world I remember when I was told well if
you step forward and do something you'll
get in trouble ever since I stepped
forward my life has been going very well
so I think it's not just making choices
it's taking risks and following your
heart my parents did it young wing did
it and I think the students of this
generation should do it as well yes
well I've traveled all around the world
and I've learned that there's a basic
truth everybody hates America and
everybody loves Americans and I think
it's because often the two stands for
quite different values Americans I think
tend to be very egalitarian open
welcoming experimental spontaneous where
America I think often is sensitive about
it power demands exceptional treatment
creates double standards and is often
accused of various kinds of moral
hypocrisy I think people who have been
here and lived here can deliver the
message there's more to America than who
happens to be in any governmental
position at any particular time and
America's the world's you know one of
its oldest democracies and one of its
largest and there are lessons that
people have learned here about diversity
take diversity for example how many
countries in the world are genuinely
diverse in the sense that people of many
different ethnic and religious
Heritage's are living together
peacefully very very few the United
States Australia Canada maybe New
Zealand there are many countries in the
world where people of different ethnic
Heritage's cannot live next to each
other without killing each other I would
go to Bosnia during the time I was in
the State Department i would go to
Bosnia or Kosovo and I'd come back to
New Haven on the weekend and it's really
a stunning thing to be in a place where
people have different ethnic backgrounds
are actually coexisting without military
police and without open violence now I
think that's an important message to
convey I think there's another message
to convey and I would say this
particularly to the students from places
like Malaysia or Singapore or China
which is don't anybody ever tell us that
Asians don't love democracy when I was a
child growing up they would say Koreans
want increases in gross national product
they don't want democracy
so when our gross national product
reaches a thousand dollars a person or
two thousand or 5,000 or 10,000 then
it's time for you to have democracy and
I often had meetings with people like
maha tier and leave Kwon Yu and Zhang Zi
min and Kim jong-il and they would start
by saying things like you have to
understand the Asian difference we don't
care as much about human rights and
democracy as you Westerners now it was a
very difficult sell right I don't know
what you're saying my father was a
democracy activist my mother's a
democracy activist I am a democracy
activist I know plenty of asians and let
me tell you what they like freedom as
much as you do more and your system is
doomed now sometimes that doesn't get
you invited back
but that's not a bad message for them to
hear and repeatedly because the one
thing they know is that they don't want
to be on the wrong side of history yes
no I believe in a point of politics the
last election I successfully one was
back in sixth grade I was trounced in
seventh grade and now it's basically it
now I mean we all have our way of making
a difference my Frank hope is that one
of you will become president the United
States and then appoint me to something
yes
well you raised a question that troubles
many justice blackmun for whom I clerked
at a different view I that your first
statement reminds us of the famous
statement about what's the difference
between capitalism and communism in the
first man exploits man but in the other
it's just the opposite I I do believe
that you know there is a possibility
under different legal systems to achieve
different kinds of results but I also do
believe there's a role for constitutions
and protections of human rights and
judicial protection of those human
rights yes right here
well I do think that that you know the
the effort of a central government to
control people so vibrant and energetic
is doomed to failure which generational
change will come great social change I
think it's happening already I think
that the information revolution is a
very important part of it I think you
could put together two simple phrases
information wants to be free and a song
of my generation all the world over it's
easy to see people everywhere want to be
free when you put informations desire
for freedom and that desire human beings
for freedom together it's unstoppable
and you as an example of someone who's
come here and enjoying the free flow of
information have a lot of information
and to convey back just remember that at
10 and men you know here was this vision
of a very imperial group of elderly
barons and suddenly they're confronted
by people in their 20s and the site of
these students confronting this
leadership stunned the world now in the
cultural revolution a lot of things
happened and nobody knew about it to
this day we're still excavating
information about it by Tiananmen Square
they were faxing for democracy and now
China democracy websites maybe block
today but they can't be blocked tomorrow
and the Chinese government itself and
private actors in civil society are
promoting exchange and I think that
Archibald Cox professor at Harvard Law
School the former Watergate special
prosecutor said the desire for freedom
once loosed is not easily cabined and I
think that applies to this situation